(classical music)
- Babe.
- Huh? Yeah?
- What are you thinking?
- (laughs) Nothin' really.
- You are not thinking nothing.
- (laughs) Yes, I am, I.
- No, you're not.
You are a thoughtful person.
- Yeah.
- There's no way that you are thinking.
I am never just not thinking
absolutely nothing.
- Right.
Right.
- That doesn't work like that.
- You definitely don't.
I do though, I swear.
I have an analogy for this.
Go with me on this, just
walk with me on this.
Come here.
- Like, literally walk with you?
- Yeah, like literally
walk with me on this.
- Okay.
- Come on.
(light chimes ringing)
Walk with me, come here.
(classical music)
Alright, so the way I see it.
- Mmm.
- We organize our thoughts
differently from one another.
Your brain is kind of like this spaghetti.
And your thoughts are like this sauce.
My brain is kind of like this waffle.
And my thoughts are like this syrup.
Now if you'll notice,
this syrup and this sauce
are the exact same amount.
- Okay.
- Your thoughts cover your brain
like tomato sauce covers
spaghetti noodles.
When I pick your brain, you're
always covered in thoughts.
- Me on the other hand,
my brain is like a waffle.
My thoughts cover my brain
like syrup on waffle squares.
Ya' know what I mean?
- Yeah.
- Right, well some waffle
squares will have syrup.
But some squares'll be totally empty.
So sometimes when you ask
me, like what am I thinking,
baby, you just got an empty waffle square.
Like I'm not saying I'm dumb,
I'm not saying I don't have thoughts,
I have lots of thoughts.
I just compartmentalize and
maybe have one thing at a time.
- This is almost insightful.
- (laughs)
- This is kind of insightful.
- It's a little bit insightful.
- Okay.
- I feel like it makes a
lot more sense to you now
and you're not gonna me
so much when you ask me,
do you have thoughts?
And I'm like, no.
(classical music)